mais madame disent que c'est pour vous
madame il ya des fraises discret mais si
c'est pour vous distraire mr bah ouais
j'en fais pardon je voulais sortie je
les ai piqué l'étalagé faut pas le parce
que vous êtes sympa bien vous voulez
enfin j pour donner moins la pièce
kovalev d'être complices dont c'est un
petit larcin sais pas non décidément la
vie a simplement mais discret merci
madame enfin la pièce là c'est un fond
vous donner c'est déplaisant mais non
j'ai beau me dire prenez les vrais
moments les élèves n'ont alors venez -
rodez des moyens frank là c'est pas moi
moi c'est du vol
c'est pas moi ah ben moi je suis
délinquants des batailles sur ce coup là
non je vais prendre un fonds alors un
front les trois ok d'accord
moi j sera et arnaqueurs a quand même
fougue les uns bonne bourre je vais vous
mettre sympathique
je vais mettre un petit ça me fait
plaisir ça fait plaisir mais comment je
le prends très bien vous aussi ya aucun
problème à laisser un peuple vous les
payez pas les fraises
non mais pas du tout alors partait en
courant si les voleurs parcours qui a
bougé pas bougé pas bougé pas bougé pas
comme ça comme ça je peux plus merci
madame pour le portage de partage c'est
normal qu'à deux on a pitié à 2 je suis
inquiet oui j'aime tout mais c'est pour
le volet non non non je ne savais même
pas ce que je ne veux pas mourir
ah bon c'est en fait chier c'est le
départ de tai chi c'est empêcher
oui c'est empêcher de voler on peut dire
ce soir on doit pas vori attendant on
peut même pas tiqué enfin il faut pas
prendre ça aux enfants à tuer même un
papa à pardon et pour être sûr de ne
rien rater de 1h10 tube abonnez vous y
mettez un peu de bleu